dire la pieuse et ses vingt mille âmes
vivent principalement de la route toute
la journée des tonnes de marchandises
sont chargés et déchargés des camions
unique moyen de transport de la région
le quartier des camionneurs est la
principale source d'emplois
conducteur
mécanicien assistant de tout âge il
travaille chaque jour dans la poussière
et la pollution
à 23 ans camara a bien réussi dans la
vie il est déjà propriétaire de deux
camions ce matin il est inquiet son
camion va s'engager sur la loarie il
doit livrer deux tonnes de sucre au
petit village de chitral
ce voyage périlleux il l'a confié à son
meilleur chauffeur
représente daou c'est mon chauffeur je
le paye 40 euros par mois il travaille
avec son petit frère c'est une bonne
équipe s'ils sont très courageux
40 euros par mois c'est le salaire moyen
au pakistan à ce prix là peu de
chauffeur accepte de risquer leur vie
sur cette route alors pour trouver des
candidats camara offre une prime de
risque de 60 euros par trajet une prime
qui motive les plus jeunes
voilà khalid c'est le petit frère de
daou il fait l'assistant pendant le
trajet les quatorze ans ce pas trop
jeune c'est la pauvreté qui l'obligent
il n'y a pas d'autres activités existent
quel est le rôle de ton petit frère
il s'occupe des manoeuvres difficiles en
indiquant les directions
ne prévient des problèmes sur la route
et s'occupe de la mécanique
[Musique]
et il travaille bien
oui car s'il fait mal son travail
je lui apprendrai pas à conduire le
camion
ouais
7 heures du matin dawood sonne le départ
[Applaudissements]
voyager sur la loarie est loin d'être
une partie de plaisir sur 240 kilomètres
la route serpente à travers la montagne
et ses corniches vertigineuse
logiquement il faut une journée pour en
arriver à bout mais peu de chauffeurs y
parviennent
daoud veut pourtant la franchir le plus
rapidement possible au mépris du danger
salut mec son objectif est de multiplier
les allers retours afin de cumuler les
primes de risque
pour y parvenir il ne s'arrête jamais et
passe sa vie dans son camion
entre le camion et moi c'est une
relation extrêmement forte il est comme
ma maison je mange je dors ici en fait
je passe plus de temps à son bord que
chez mois
d'aout conduit depuis bientôt dix ans le
camion lui n'a plus d'âge le compteur
est d'ailleurs resté bloqué sur 776 1000
km depuis bien longtemps
peu importe les deux frères l'ont
décorée comme leur propre maison les
photos de feu benazir buttho y partagent
l'espace avec celle de pop star indienne
idole de la jeunesse pakistanaise
à 2000 mètres d'altitude
les premières difficultés surviennent
la fonte des neiges forme des torrents
qui coupent creuse et emporte la route
sur des centaines de mètres
pour franchir ce torrent on avance en
première très très doucement à cause des
trous au fond de l'eau
quelles sont vraiment les risques quand
on est chargé comme aujourd'hui on
risque de casser l'arbre de direction
mais pire que tout on risque de se
renverser
à chaque passage dangereux les pneus
sont déformés entaillée par les rochers
alors khalid les vérifie un par un pour
éviter tout éclatement
sur la loire il les problèmes ne
s'arrêtent jamais alors pour les oublier
les chauffeurs fume la drogue local
[Musique]
quand je fus du haschich
je ne pense plus à la route
tous les problèmes que je vais bientôt
rencontrer
et en plus je ne réfléchis même plus
gros danger
la tête dans les nuages daoud devient un
danger supplémentaire sur la route de
nombreux accidents sont causés par cette
consommation de drogue
devant le nombre croissant de blessés
sur la loire y le gouvernement
pakistanais a entrepris depuis quatre
ans de creuser un tunnel à travers la
montagne
on traversera bientôt la montagne ça va
vraiment me changer la vie
comme ça on aura moins difficultés pour
travailler mais pour l'instant on doit
continuer à franchir le col à plus de
3000 mètres d'altitude et on ne sait
jamais si on réussira à passer daoud
habite à quelques pas de ce chantier
avant d'attaquer la montagne il s'arrête
toujours pour embrasser ses enfants sa
vie c'est sur la route qu'elles défilent
tu les vois souvent tes fils pas
malheureusement pas beaucoup et eux ils
seront conducteur est peut-être
daouda deux garçons et une fille dans
cette vallée très à cheval sur la
religion on oblige les femmes à se
cacher du regard des hommes daoud
empêchera même sa mère sa femme et sa
fille de nous rencontrer
comment tu vois ton avenir
il n'y a pas d'avenir ici on travaille
c'est tout on n'y a pas d'avenir dans ce
job mais tu voudrais pas acheter un
camion un jour je gagne tout juge de
quoi nourrir ma famille alors comment
veux tu que j'économise pour un camion
moi je vais économiser 30 mille euros et
je vais l'acheter ce camion
sera de faire de décoration il ouvrira
ce sera le premier camion de la ferme et
que j'ai de l'argent je l'achète
[Applaudissements]
après deux heures d'arrêt les deux
frères reprenne la route
ils attaquent maintenant la partie la
plus difficile de l'ascension une zone
où la fonte des neige provoque avalanche
et glissements de terrain
[Applaudissements]
en moins d'une heure ils vont passer de
2000 à 3000 m d'altitude
[Musique]
une ascension à donner le vertige aux
routiers les plus aguerris
ainsi quelle idée sans la route a pas
l'air bonne devant
le camion peine
sur les pentes abruptes la vitesse tombe
à dix kilomètres heure
2800 m
le manque d'oxygène accentue la fatigue
et diminue la concentration
[Musique]
le moindre geste devient alors un effort
il faut lutter pour rester éveillé
[Musique]
encore 300 mètres avant le col et son
auberge
[Musique]
ça y est on est arrivé au sommet fait
vraiment froid ici
regarde là bas c'est la zone des 45
virage
la descente est terrible c'est vraiment
très dangereux il faut freiner tout le
temps et les freins chauffe la route est
si étroite que dans les virages on ne
peut même pas se croiser avec d'autres
camions alors il faut être attentif et
ne jamais lâché son volant n'ont jamais
devant l'auberge du col les camionneurs
vérifient que leurs marchandises sont
bien arrivés à l'intérieur d'autres
évacuent les tensions de la montée et se
prépare pour la suite devant un bon plat
de moutons bouillie la spécialité de la
vallée
quelles sont les qualités indispensables
pour traverser la montagne
il faut avoir le coeur solide c'est à
dire
il faut du courage et de l'expérience
celui qui n'a jamais eu d'accident de
problèmes mécaniques ne s'en sortira
jamais dans cette montagne
pour daoud et son frère il est temps
d'attaquer la zone des 45 virage
[Applaudissements]
à partir d'ici tout devient un problème
la route est extrêmement glissante
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas trop de
neige fondue
sinon ça sera l'enfer
[Musique]
franchir ces virages relève de l'épreuve
de force
l'enjeu est simple descendre sans jamais
s'arrêter et prier pour ne pas croiser
un autre camion dans les virages
t
[Musique]
la neige fondue a rendu la route boueuse
le moindre coup de frein un peu trop
brusque et le camion devient
incontrôlable c'est le tout droit sur et
dans le ravin
quand ça glisse je ne peux rien faire et
je suis obligé d'attendre que ça se
passe je ne peux pas freiné
et si je le fais le camion peut partir
n'importe où
regarde j'arrive même pas à tourner le
volant ça sert à rien
oui c'est comme ça la vie ici
sa vie daoud la doit à la maîtrise
parfaite de son camion mais ce qu'il ne
maîtrise pas c'est la colère de la
nature comme les avalanches qui arrache
tout sur leur passage
ce poteau à haute tension en a récemment
fait les frais
[Musique]
regarde ça les avalanches ont arraché le
poteau électrique et maintenant on a
très peur des fils qui pendent
mais en quoi c'est dangereux
si on touche les fils avec le toit du
camion ça fait fondre les pneus mais
surtout ça peut nous électrocuté
[Musique]
un dernier virage et les deux frères
arrivent enfin dans la vallée de chitral
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route y est plutôt bonne elle est
goudronnée et protégés par des
contreforts cali pourra bientôt avoir sa
leçon de conduite
mais quelques kilomètres plus loin en
bas dans la vallée c'est une mauvaise
surprise qui les attend
une partie de la montagne est écroulé
sur la route
impossible d'aller plus loin
[Applaudissements]
c'est grave et oui regarde la montagne
s'écoule encore
la route est complètement bloqué il va
falloir au moins une journée entière à
ce petit tracteur pour tout déblayer
mais il n'existe pas une autre route non
malheureusement c'est la seule de la
vallée
[Applaudissements]
le flanc de la montagne reste instable
et un flot de rocher sans décroche
continuellement
dessous au péril de leur vie les
ouvriers travaillent sans relâche pour
réouvrir la route au plus vite
est fait attention la machine ça coûte
cher à l'hercules faut bien je travaille
un rocher se décrochent
et percute l'avant du tracteur
pourquoi tu prends tous ces risques
il faut bien que quelqu'un le fasse ce
travail
allez j'y retourne
[Applaudissements]
de part et d'autre de l'éboulement en
file indienne une trentaine de camions
attendent que le tracteur ouvre la route
certains sont bloqués depuis plusieurs
jours alors chacun prend son mal en
patience et fait passer le temps comme
il plaît
la route était déjà bloqué hier soir
depuis j'attends c'est un rêve
constamment c'est la faute au
gouvernement qui n'entretient pas les
routes dans cette région pourtant on a
besoin pour travailler quand on reste
bloqué comme aujourd'hui on perd
beaucoup d'argent
un bien petit tracteur pour une si
grosse montagne tout le monde attend
l'arrivée du bulldozer gouvernementale
envoyé par la ville de drogue situé à
quelques kilomètres de l'éboulement
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain matin au pied de la
montagne écroulé le bulldozer tant
attendu est arrivé
en quelques coups de pelle il ouvre un
passage dans la coulée de pierre
on a bien travaillé
[Musique]
n'ont ils pas aussi dit ça peut encore
bouger
[Musique]
allez avance on a perdu assez de temps
de picon tu as ton de trois jours le
passage reste temporaire car la montagne
continue de s'écrouler
les pierres qui tombent les premiers
camions s'engagent les uns après les
autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrive le tour de daoud
son petit frère passe devant pour le
guider
tout s'est bien passé ils peuvent enfin
terminer leur voyage
[Musique]
daoud est fier de son petit frère qui
l'a aidé à franchir la montagne sans
casse ni accident il décide de leurs
récompenses et
allez vas-y va prendre ma place
[Musique]
la route est facile maintenant alors je
le mets au volant
pourquoi tu fais ça
il doit commencer à apprendre le métier
ça sera facile
[Applaudissements]
allez vas-y démarre
allez accélère
[Applaudissements]
tu sembles inquiet non non non tant que
je reste à côté de lui tout ira bien
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas trop jeune pour conduire si
mais c'est le métier que je veux faire
et tu as peur
[Applaudissements]
dans la région pas d'école de conduite
ce sont les aînés qui enseigne aux plus
jeunes
allez avance engage toi il n'ya personne
passe une vitesse
allez roule roule prendre la vitesse
passez une vitesse maintenant où tu vas
calais
[Musique]
vas-y change
trop tard imbéciles freine maintenant je
m'écoute je te remets une
ne lâche pas ton volant petit con
je te dis de ne jamais lâcher ton volant
c'est trop dangereuse
aide à aller c'est fini arrête toi là
maintenant aller derrière ce camion
c'est fini mais le frein à main allez
dehors des galas
dégage
[Musique]
des sens
il conduit bien alors ouais pas mal
quand même
il deviendrait conducteur alors
s'il reste avec moi encore deux ou trois
ans il pourra faire ce
pour quoi tu frappes il lâche le volant
c'est bien trop dangereux de faire ça on
risque notre vie il doit s'en souvenir
pour toujours
khalid et daoud arrive enfin à chitral
pour parcourir les 240 kilomètres de là
lowery ils ont mis près de quatre jours
il faut maintenant des charges est
rapidement la marchandise et reprendre
la route au plus vite pour tenter de
faire encore un aller retour avant la
fin du mois merci pour ton courage
allez encore un dernier sac et on rentre
on a bien travaillé dans son coin khalid
enterre ses illusions l'avis de
camionneurs il l'avait rêvé autrement